This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇妙现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字“2”%，可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回溯往事》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。1984年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回溯往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你们是在与一位知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出的信号是，你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《知难而进》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. A sincere welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are on this world, on this planet. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we break down the psychology of our 20s. There are some people out there who we can just all agree we basically aspire to be. The people who have it all, they're intelligent, they're business-minded, they take care of themselves and their relationships, they are kind, they are confident, they are hot, smart and rich to use the catchphrase of our guests today.
欢迎回到本节目。真诚地欢迎大家再次收听本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你们在这个世界的哪个地方，在这个星球的哪个角落。非常高兴能邀请你们回来收听新的一集。当我们剖析20多岁时的心理学时。有些人，我们都可以一致认为，基本上是我们渴望成为的对象。那些拥有一切的人，他们聪明、有商业头脑、懂得照顾自己和人际关系、他们善良、自信、性感、聪明且富有——用我们今天嘉宾的口头禅来说。
I think we can learn a lot from these kinds of individuals and the mindset that they have cultivated for themselves. I don't talk about entrepreneurship or business a lot on this podcast because it is a psychology podcast. But when we get down to it, there is a lot of psychology involved. And I do get so many questions about it revolving around how you can take risks on yourself, how you can find your niche. What is the secret to being successful and creative in your 20s? And how can we balance all of that ambition whilst also having a fierce, confident aura, cultivating wealth in our life in whatever form, and I was lucky enough to find someone who has discovered that very formula. Today, we have on a special guest, the founder of
我认为我们可以向这类人以及他们为自己培养的心态学到很多东西。在这个播客中，我其实不太常谈论创业或商业，因为它是一个心理学播客。但当我们深入探讨时，其中涉及大量的心理学。而且我确实收到了很多关于这方面的问题，围绕着你如何敢于对自己下注、如何找到自己的细分市场。在20多岁时获得成功和富有创造力的秘诀是什么？我们又该如何在保持这种雄心勃勃的同时，拥有一种凌厉、自信的气场，以某种形式在生活中积累财富呢？我很幸运地找到了一个发现了这个秘诀公式的人。今天，我们请到了一位特别的嘉宾，她是……
Hot, Smart, and Rich Maggie Sellers. Maggie, can you introduce yourself? Well, first of all, thank you so much for having me. I'm truly honored. It's also so interesting hearing your voice over Zoom because I feel like I've heard it in my ears for so long, and I'm just so grateful to be here. But yeah, I'm Maggie Sellers. I'm also from a Commonwealth country, Canada. I emigrated to the U.S. almost seven years ago to work in really high-growth startups. I was in high-growth startups for a super long time. And then I ended up really having this late bulb moment where I realized celebrities were the future of distribution to reach a new audience at a super inexpensive way. So I ended up working for some of the biggest celebrities in the world at a management company. I helped build some
性感、聪明且富有的创始人玛吉·塞勒斯。玛吉，你能介绍一下你自己吗？首先，非常感谢邀请我来。我真的感到非常荣幸。通过Zoom听到你的声音也觉得非常有趣，因为我觉得我的耳朵里听你的声音已经很久了，我真的非常感激能来到这里。但是的，我是玛吉·塞勒斯。我也是来自一个英联邦国家——加拿大。我大约七年前移民到美国，在一些高增长的初创公司工作。我在高增长的初创公司呆了超级长的时间。然后我真的迎来了一个醍醐灌顶的时刻，我意识到名人是分发内容的未来，能以超低的成本触达全新的受众。因此，我最终在一家管理公司为世界上一些最大的名人工作。我帮他们建立了一些。
some brands for them. I did brand partnerships, creative strategy. And then I fell in love with early stage investing when a lot of young brands would come to us in exchange for equity, ownership in the brand versus cash. Ends it up launching a corporate venture arm or record labels corporate venture arm. And then I've spent the last two years really building HSR as a media company, media investment holding company to empower women to become their hottest, smartest, richest self. We started with short form content. We're very quickly expanding into long form content. And I'm just so grateful every single day to be helping make an impact in so many incredible women's lives to just be authentically themselves. Oh my goodness. I love that. I love everything
为他们建立一些品牌。我做过品牌合作、创意战略。后来，当许多年轻品牌找到我们，用股权、品牌所有权来代替现金作为交换时，我便爱上了早期投资。最后创立了一个企业风投部门或唱片公司的企业风投部门。在过去的两年里，我真正地将HSR打造成一家媒体公司、媒体投资控股公司，旨在赋能女性，让她们成为最性感、最聪明、最富有的自己。我们从短内容起步。我们正在非常迅速地向长内容扩展。我每天都无比感激，能帮助对如此多不可思议的女性的生活产生影响，让她们能够真实地做自己。哦天哪。我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢一切。
that it stands for, especially since you know your shit. Like you embody the hot smart, hot smart rich ethos and not in the way that i think people typically think like it's such a mindset thing for you and just i think an incredible an incredible um mission to just be like women can have a space in like male dominated spaces they can do it all like they are smart they can be wealthy they can be like this attractive confident force what was like you kind of explained how you came to develop hot smart bridge. What was like your motivation? Was there like a light bulb moment for you where you were like people kind of need this? Like we need like a finance brogue community for women. Yeah, so badly. I think it's like a lot of little moments in my life that
它所代表的意义，尤其是既然你深谙此道。就像你体现了性感聪明、性感聪明富有的精神内核，而且不是我认为人们通常想的那种方式——对你来说这是一种心态，我认为这是一个不可思议的、不可思议的使命，就是让女性在男性主导的空间里占有一席之地，她们可以做到这一切——她们很聪明，她们可以富有，她们可以成为那种有吸引力的、自信的力量。你刚才解释了你是如何发展出“性感聪明富有”这个概念的。你的动机是什么？有没有那么一个醍醐灌顶的时刻，让你觉得人们某种程度上需要这个？就像我们需要为女性打造一个金融兄弟社群一样。是的，非常需要。我觉得这是我生活中的许多小时刻。
laddered up to finally being able to take the plunge of just people thinking one thing about me or these kind of passive aggressive compliments or backhanded compliments of like, oh, you're so much nicer than I thought you were. You're actually really smart. And I think I just over time felt really worn down by those small things. But then there were obviously a lot of like bigger moments in people's lives that just make you realize that you want to make a change. And there's one story in particular that always comes back to me where I, you know, was working at a at a startup and I was taking on so much responsibility and just like doing what I did at every startup, which was acting as if it was my own working crazy hours, more responsibility, no more money. And, you know,
一步步累积，最终让我有勇气迈出这一步：人们对我的看法，或者这种被动攻击的赞美，又或者是这种含沙射影的夸奖，比如，“噢，你比我想象的要好很多。你其实真的很聪明。”随着时间的推移，我觉得这些小事真的把我磨得很累。但与此同时，生活中显然也有许多更大的时刻，让你意识到自己想要做出改变。有一个故事特别触动我，我当时在一个初创公司工作，承担了大量的责任，就像我在每个初创公司做的那样——表现得就像这是我自己的公司一样，疯狂加班，承担更多责任，却拿着同样的薪水。然后，
I had been negotiating back and forth with my male boss at the time trying to just like advocate for myself and be taken seriously. And there was just this moment where he was like, I just don't think that you're worth it. And I was like, well, then I'm going to leave. And I never thought that he would let me leave. I thought ultimately it was going to be like, of course, I would never let you leave. And I left. And I had no idea what I was going to do.
我当时在和当时的男老板进行反复谈判，试图为自己据理力争，想要得到认真的对待。然后就有这样一个时刻，他说：“我觉得你不值这个价。”我说：“好吧，那我要离职。”我从来没想过他会让我走。我以为最终的结果会是，当然，我绝不会让你走。但我还是走了。而且我根本不知道自己接下来要做什么。
I had 60 days to get deported back to Canada because of my visa status. and I just had to figure it out. And it was this really interesting moment where everything I had known kind of melted away. And it was just like I bet 100% on myself. And I think it was through the last three or four years of working mostly for men, mostly for men talent, mostly just around men in this space where I didn't have the same credentials that a lot of them had. I didn't go to an Ivy League school. I, you know, didn't go to investment banking. I didn't have any connections. Like I've built my entire network myself for seven years since I got here. And I just realized how lonely I felt, but how much I loved what I was doing. And I was like, I wish there was
由于我的签证状态，我只有60天的时间被遣返回加拿大。而我只能硬着头皮去解决这个问题。那是一个非常有趣的时刻，我所熟悉的一切仿佛都融化了。这就好比我百分之百地押注于自己。我想，在过去三四年里，我大部分时间都是为男性工作，大部分时间都是为男性人才工作，在这个空间里周围全都是男人，我并没有他们许多人拥有的那些资历。我没有上过常春藤盟校，我没有去过投资银行，我没有任何人脉。自从我来到这里以来的七年里，我的整个人脉网络都是我自己建立的。我只是意识到自己感到多么孤独，但我又多么热爱我正在做的事情。我当时就想，我希望有。
just more people that I could do this with that I related to. And then there was this other light bulb moment where I saw a lot of deals and it was often, you know, geared towards selling to women. And women control 85% of consumer spend in the U.S. Yet we get 2% of venture dollars. And, and And it was often men that were getting the deals, going to their wives or their girlfriends or their friends and asking for like, do you use this or what products compute this. And I'm like, women are literally giving away the secrets to make men wealthy because we control the spend. We know what people are buying. So if I can help tell women that what actually makes them good consumers is what would make you a good business person or a good investor, then I'm actually going to teach the fishermen to fish, not just give him the fish. And so that's kind of what started and I think just has spiraled from there to be so much like of a mission for me.
能有更多跟我有共鸣的人能和我一起做这件事。然后还有另一个醍醐灌顶的时刻，我看到了很多交易，而且通常是针对向女性销售产品。在美国，女性控制着85%的消费支出。然而我们却只获得了2%的风险投资资金。而且，而且。通常都是那些男人拿到交易，然后去问他们的妻子、女朋友或女性朋友，问她们“你们用这个吗”或者“什么产品能算出这个”。我觉得，女性简直是在拱手让出能让男人变富有的秘密，因为我们掌控着消费支出。我们知道人们在买什么。所以，如果我能帮助告诉女性，正是她们作为好消费者的特质，才会让你成为一个优秀的商人和投资者，那么我实际上是在教她们如何捕鱼，而不仅仅是直接给她们一条鱼。所以这差不多就是一切的起点，而且我认为从那以后它就像滚雪球一样发展，对我来说已经变成了如此宏大的使命。
But it's been really fun along the way, which I honestly haven't been able to say I've had a lot of excitement in my career. But I haven't had fun like every single day because I really am like the own writer of my destiny now. Honestly like hearing you talk about this, I'm getting so inspired. Yeah. I have like no interest in like investing or in venture capital and I'm like, what am I going to invest in next? like my money is my power. I've never really considered it, which is probably not a great thing to own up to. I think that's part of the problem is that we are not encouraged to even think about the little things that we can do. And I think that is where the way that women think about money
但这一路走来真的非常有趣，老实说，我以前没法说我的职业生涯有过多少兴奋感。但我现在每天都过得很有趣，因为我真的是自己命运的书写者了。老实说，听你讲这些，我受到了极大的启发。是的。我对投资或风险投资其实没什么兴趣，但我现在却在想：我接下来要投资什么？我的钱就是我的力量。我以前从来没有真正考虑过这一点，承认这一点可能不是件好事。我认为这正是问题的一部分，那就是我们甚至不被鼓励去思考我们可以采取的微小行动。我认为这就是女性对金钱的看法。
is just so fundamentally different than the way that men think about money, that it's almost just changing the perception of how hard it is to even, think about it. It's like getting people excited to talk about it is part of what the purpose is. I will come on record and say, I know what I'm good at. I know what I'm not. If you want to be a, you know, Wall Street guru ninja, I'm probably not the person that's going to teach you how to do that, but I will teach you how to change your mindset towards money, your mindset towards how you think about yourself, your mindset towards how you think about collaboration. And there will be tips and trips along the way and a community to help you build whatever your dream is, whether it's starting a
与男性的金钱观有着根本的不同，以至于它几乎改变了人们对这件事有多难的看法。让人兴奋地谈论它正是目的的一部分。我要公开声明，我知道自己擅长什么，不擅长什么。如果你想成为一个华尔街的世外高人，我可能不是那个能教你如何做到这一点的人，但我会教你如何改变你的金钱观念、你对自己看法的观念、以及你对合作看法的观念。这一路上会有各种小贴士和技巧，还有一个社区来帮助你构建你的梦想，无论是创业、投资公司、担任营销负责人，还是你对职业的任何雄心壮志。我从你刚才的话中发现非常有趣的一点是我们是如何看待金钱的。非常有趣的是，我妈妈其实是一位经济学家，很多人并不知道这一点。所以你可能会认为我对金钱的态度会非常不同、非常理性、非常倾向于积累。但我觉得我当时在学校和大学里接受的社会化过程，让我看到了一群关心财富管理、财富增长和投资等事物的人。而我觉得我——我没有看到自己被代表在那里。我觉得我更倾向于情感的那一面。我觉得我自己。
company, investing in a company, being the head of marketing or whatever your career ambition is for you. What I found really interesting about what you just said was how we think about money. And what's really interesting is that my mom is actually an economist, which a lot of people don't know. And so you would think that I have this attitude towards money that would be very different and very rational and very kind of accumulative. But I just feel like I was then socialized like at school and at university to see this group of people who cared about, you know, wealth management and wealth growth and investing and all those things. And I was like, I don't, I don't see myself represented there. Like I see myself in this more emotional side of things. I see that myself
在这更偏向心理学的一面。所以，你能够想出。基本上类似于教练品牌，几乎就像整个品牌。而且我认为对你来说最主要的是，我们如何帮助坚强、独立的女性克服她们的冒名顶替综合征？以及我们如何做到让你在一个你以前认为自己不配呆的空间里看到自己的代表，无论是推出你自己的商业项目，还是从事你梦想中的职业，无论是与你想约会的人约会，还是在拥挤的房间里说出你的意见。你最喜欢的标语之一是“你在快节奏的世界里是慢生活的CEO”。现在，我认为在这里指出这一点非常重要，因为你知道我喜欢。
in this more like psychological side. So the fact that you have come up with, Essentially what is like a coaching brand almost, like this whole brand. And the primary thing I think for you is how do we get strong, independent women over their imposter syndrome? And how do we make it so that you see yourself represented in a space that previously you thought you didn't deserve to be in, of whether that's launching your own business, whether that's in like your dream career, whether that's like dating the people you want to date, like speaking your opinion in like a crowded room. One of my favorite taglines that you have is like you are the CEO of a slow life in a fast world. Now, I think that's really important to pull out here because you know I love
慢生活。你知道我喜欢轻松的生活、温和的生活。它并不完全关注生产力，也不关注尽你所能去做尽可能多的事情；你刚才提到，当你这样做的时候，你精疲力竭，但你的老板仍然对你说：“嗯，你还是不值这个价。”当你创立了自己的公司后，这对你意味着什么？你如何在快节奏的世界里——或者说在快车道上——体现这种慢生活？这是一个非常棒的问题，也是我充满热情的领域，因为我认为我们完全走错了追求生产力的道路。人们认为忙碌就是生产力，但事实远非如此。我很忙吗？我当然很忙。但我可以给你举一个很好的例子，讲一个很棒的故事。我。
the slow life. You know I love the soft life, the gentle life. it's not all focused on like productivity and like doing as much as you can and you kind of spoke about how when you were doing that you were so burnt out and you still had people your boss say to you like well you're still not worth it what does it mean to you now having started your own company how do you embody this like slow life in a fast world or in the fast lane I guess it's such a great question and it's something that I feel so passionate about because I think that we have totally just gone down the wrong way of productivity. People think busyness is productivity and it is so not. Am I busy? Of course I am. But I'll give you a great example and a great story. I have been
出差比平时多得多。我周一刚回来。今天是周三。我周六又要离开两周去印度。这周我的生活中有太多事情在同时发生。我的背受伤了。所以我有一个脊柱专家预约。我有所有这些医生的预约。我有所有这些我许下的承诺。我甚至开始感到自己有点不知所措：“我该怎么做到这一切？”过去的我会选择早上6点起床，半夜12点睡觉，疯狂喝咖啡，跳过健身，放弃心理健康。而这对于打造一场马拉松式的业务、而不是短跑式的业务来说，简直是极具破坏性的，于是我坐下来对自己说：“这个业务最重要的三件事是什么？好吧，在这之下最重要的三件事是什么？”然后我写下来：有没有什么是我可以委派给别人的？有没有什么我可以从日程表里拿掉以完成所有事情的？一旦你把事情非常简单地拆解开来，你就能明白，是的，确实有一些非常重要的事情，别人正指望你去做。
traveling a lot more than normal. I just got back on Monday. It's Wednesday. I'm leaving again on Saturday for two weeks to go to India. I have so many things going on in my life this week. I've injured my back. So I have a spy and a specialist appointment. I have all these doctor's appointments. I have all these commitments that I've made. And I could start to feel myself just be like, how am I going to do this? And the old me would have been like wake up at 6 a.m. go to bed at 12, like coffee, coffee, like skip my workout, skip my mental health. And that is just so detrimental to the longevity of building a marathon versus a sprint of a business that I sat down with myself and I was like, what are the three most important things of the business? Okay, what are the three
但男友最近教了我一件事，每当我感到不知所措时，我每天都会问自己这个问题：“这件事是紧急的，还是重要的？”因为紧急情况。通常是别人的待办事项清单。而完成别人的待办事项清单不是你的工作。你的工作是做对你、对你的业务、对你效力的公司而言重要的事情。
most important things underneath that. Then I wrote down, is there anything that I can delegate? Is there anything that I can take off of my calendar to be able to accomplish everything? And once you break things down very easily, you're able to understand how, yes, there are things that are really important that people are relying on you for. But there's something that my boyfriend recently just taught me that I ask myself every single day when I'm feeling overwhelmed is, is this urgent or is this important? Because urgency. is typically somebody else's to-do list. And it is not your job to do somebody else's to-do list. It is your job to do what is important for you, your business, your company that you work for,
或你的职业生涯。所以，与其去处理别人紧急的待办事项清单，最重要的是去做对你来说重要的事情。其他人都可以等。所以你可以做一些小贴士和技巧，比如，你知道，你可以进行不同的时间段划分、日程天数划分。有时我甚至会设置一个自动回复邮件，说由于X、Y、Z的原因，我会回复得比较慢。是的，如果你在大公司工作，你可能需要和你的经理一起解决一些事情。但我确实认为，如果你真的很透明、沟通很好并且解释了你在做什么，你们应该都在朝着同一个目标努力。当你仍然拥有。
or your career. And so instead of tackling somebody else's urgent to-do list, it is the most important for you to do what's important for you. And everybody else can wait. And so there's like little tips and tricks that you can do where, you know, you can just do different time blocking, day blocking. Sometimes I even put out and out of office just saying I'm going to be slow to respond because of X, Y, and Z. And yes, if you work at a big corporation, there might be things you have to work through with your manager. But I do think that if you are really transparent and you have great communication and you explain what you are doing, you should all be working towards the same goal. It is easier for people now to be able to work together when you still have
界限时，人们现在更容易合作了。我绝对。100%同意。而且这也是我们在播客中经常说的一点，对吧？界限是尊重的标志。界限是奉献、忠诚和爱的标志。因为我最没有界限的时候，实际上是我最让大家失望的时候。因为……完全是这样。对吧？你过度承诺，你说你能做某事，因为你不想让他们失望。然而，如果你有这样的界限，说：“抱歉，我6点就要下班了。就这样。”你知道的，你不会给别人留下你能做到超出能力范围的事的印象。我记得当时在企业工作时——作为一名管理顾问，我在墨尔本。我现在住在悉尼。我的家人全。
boundaries. I absolutely. 100% agree. And also something that we say a lot on the podcast, right? Boundaries are a sign of respect. Boundaries are a sign of dedication, loyalty, and love. Because the time that I have had the least amount of boundaries has actually been when I've disappointed the most people. Because... Totally. Right? Like you over commit, you say you can do something because you don't want to let them down. Whereas if you had the boundary of saying, I'm sorry, I'm clocking off at six. And that's that. You know, you don't impress upon someone that you can do more than you can do. And I remember being like, when I was at my corporate job, like working as a management consultant, I was in Melbourne. I live in Sydney now. And my family all
都住在墨尔本。那天是我奶奶的生日。我答应过要去参加她的生日晚宴。而当时我在上班。我在一个由五个男人组成的团队里。在一个由五个男人组成的团队里。而且。这虽然不是一个性别问题，但这对我来说确实带有性别色彩，因为我觉得自己没法说：“嘿，伙计们，我要去参加我奶奶的生日。”这是一种情感上的纠结。嗯，我身处一个五人男性团队中，我们正在为澳大利亚一个庞大的消费行业机构做一份生产力报告。我的老板说：“不好意思，伙计们，我要你们所有人留到9点。”最后，我（你知道的）还是选择离开（你知道的），当时我想：“好吧，好吧，当然，我能做到。”并且。
live in Melbourne. And it was my grandma's birthday. And I had promised to go to her birthday dinner. And I'm at my job. And I'm in a team of five men. And I'm in a team of five men. And, It's not a gendered thing, but this is, it was gendered for me and that I didn't feel like I could say, hey, guys, like, I'm going to go to my grandma's birthday. Like, it was this, like, emotional thing. Um, and I'm in this team of five men and we're doing a productivity report for a huge, like, a huge consumer industry body in Australia. And my boss is like, sorry, guys, I'm going to need you all to stay till nine. And I ended up, you know, still leaving, you know, I was like, yeah, yeah, sure, I can do that. And. And I was like, yeah, yeah, sure, I can do that. but then I ended up leaving at eight instead of nine and then everyone was pissed at me and I was still late for like my grandma's birthday and she was I could see like quite upset so if I just had the boundary of like no I'm sorry I'm happy to start earlier tomorrow but I this is a hard stop for me it's like no one would have been hurt yes maybe they would have been initially disappointed but there's a respect there of like I respect you enough to be open about what I'm doing and what I needed
然后我想：“好吧，好吧，当然，我能做到。”但结果我8点就走了，而不是9点，然后每个人都对我很生气，而且我去我奶奶的生日晚宴还是迟到了，她看起来非常难过。所以，如果我当时有这样的界限，说：“不，对不起，我很高兴明天能早点开始，但这是我的硬性截止时间。”这就好比没有人会受伤。是的，他们最初可能会感到失望，但这里有一种尊重，那就是“我足够尊重你，所以对我在做什么以及我在工作之外需要什么保持坦诚”，而且你最好也足够尊重我，说点什么。但因为这是一个组织中的资深男性人物，而且周围全都是男人，他们很多人其实都没有伴侣——很多人都相当年轻，他们中没有多少人真的有这种家庭承诺——当然他们也许有，只是当时没有——所以要做到这一点要难得多。而且我觉得，太有趣了，我总是说词汇很重要，语言很重要，你说了好多次“对不起”，作为一个加拿大人，这句话经常脱口而出，但我认为你刚才说了一个非常棒的观点，那就是你会说：“其实，谢谢你的理解。我需要因为我奶奶的生日在下午6点离开，这是一个提前商定好的安排，我之前也跟你说过。谢谢。
outside of work and you better kind of respect me enough to say something but because it was like this senior male figure in the organization and there were all these guys and like none of them really had like partners like a lot of them were like quite younger none of them really like had these family commitments i'm sure they did just not at that time like it was so much harder to do it and i think you know it's so funny i always say like words matter and language matters and you said i'm sorry a lot and coming from a canadian it comes out of my mouth a lot but i think you said something really great where it's like you say I actually thank you for your understanding. I need to leave at 6 p.m. for my grandmother's birthday, which is a previous commitment, which I told you about. Thank you for
你的理解。我明天早上7点就会到办公室，比其他人早三个小时来完成我那部分的备忘录工作。我很高兴能在对我们双方都有利的时间来复查它。”是的，确实有些老板不会尊重这一点，并希望你成为那种吓得瑟瑟发抖、只会说“非常抱歉”的人。但那也不是一个你应该长期工作的环境，因为它不利于你的成功和发展。所以我觉得这就是诸如“性感聪明富有”作为一种心态的体现。这就像是我们如何改变人们的语言和协作方式。因此，我们要使用像“谢谢你的理解”这样的语言，而不是“对不起”，因为我们不应该为以下事实感到抱歉：
your understanding. I will be in the office tomorrow at 7 a.m. three hours earlier than when everybody else is getting in to finish my part of the work. And I'm happy to review it at a time that's beneficial for both of us. And yes, there are some bosses that will not respect that and want you to be this like scared person of like, I'm so sorry. But that's also not an. environment that you should want to work in long term because it's not fostering your success in development. And so I think it's things like just even again like this is hot smart rich as a mindset. It's like how do we change people's language and change collaboration. And so it's using language like thank you for your understanding versus I'm sorry because we shouldn't be sorry that
我们在工作之外还有生活。这在我身上也表现出了一种讨好型人格的行为。另外，“对不起”这句话也是我发现自己。一直在说的话。我想这一定是个。是的，这是一个非常好的习惯，需要学会从“为占据空间和为自己站出来而感到抱歉”转变为“谢谢你尊重这一点”。你不需要为此感到抱歉，而是要说：“谢谢你尊重我的界限和自主权，并且真正像尊重一个有细微差别、不仅仅局限于工作、不仅仅局限于伴侣、不仅仅局限于任何单一身份的完整的人那样尊重我。”
we have a life outside of work. It's such people please a behavior on my part as well. Also the I'm sorry thing is something that I find myself. doing all the time. I think it must be. Yeah, it is a really good habit to learn of switching the switching from being apologetic for taking up space and for standing up for yourself. That's not something that you need to feel sorry for to being like, thank you for respecting that. Like, thank you for respecting my boundaries and my autonomy and actually just like respecting me as a person who is nuanced and who is not just their job, who is not just a partner, who is not just anything.
完全正确。我想进入我们今天的第一个话题，那就是如何变得性感。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
Exactly. I want to move into our first topic of the day, which is how to be hot. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
去超越那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是2%，可在IHeart Radio应用、
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app,
苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回溯往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，1984对我来说意义重大，不只是因为快克。我随时准备在白天聊聊快克，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so.
他们还没说完那句话。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯往事》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
They're finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们都在盯着记分板看。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
因为你觉得当你在人世间时做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地成为一个好人。和我科尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，进行关于治愈、
Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
格雷格·莱斯利和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这件事还没完。
Greg Lesbian and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱情陷阱》播客。好的，玛吉，性感、聪明、富有。在这个由美丽的词汇组成的序列中，性感是第一个词。要成为所谓的性感，实际上需要具备什么？因为我想我们都知道这不仅仅是外表。我们都知道这一点。我们想成为一个被认为有吸引力的人，但它其实比外表更具心理层面。这是一种心智模式。我们如何为自己激活那种性感的思维模式呢？是的。我太喜欢这个问题了。而且我觉得，你知道，这很有趣，因为当人们听到我是一个“性感、聪明、富有的女孩”时，总是会大跌眼镜。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, Maggie, hot smart rich. Hot is the first word in this sequence of. beautiful words. What does it actually take to be quote unquote hot? Because I think we know it's not all physical. We all know that. We want to be someone who is perceived as attractive, but it is actually more psychological than it is physical. It is a mental mindset. How do we kind of activate that hot mindset for ourselves? Yeah. I love this question. And I think, you know, it's so funny because people are always like so thrown off when they hear I'm a hot, smart, rich girl.
但我觉得，正如你所说，性感是一种心态。它真正始于自信，因为无论对你来说自信意味着什么，做最自信的自己对我而言才是真正的性感。我觉得，对我来说，走进来并感到性感，体现在我说话的力量、我的意图以及我如何让别人感受到。这才是性感的。这因人而异。但对我来说，性感的感觉就像是我可以走进一个我不认识任何人的房间，
But I think to your point exactly, being hot is such a state of mind. And it really starts with confidence because being your most confident self in whatever that is for you is what is true hotness to me. I think, you know, even for me coming in and feeling hot is being powerful in my words and my intentions and how I make people feel. That is hot. Like there is, it's going to be different for everybody. But for me, being hot is feeling like I can walk into a room where I don't know anybody,
不看手机，并感到性感和自信，觉得自己就是那个女孩。我就是那个走进房间的女孩，无论我穿什么，无论那天我看起来怎么样，也无论我处于生理周期的哪个阶段，这只是一种自信和态度，我觉得我们作为女性——正如你刚才所说——感受到了如此多的冒名顶替综合征。我们觉得自己配得上呆在那里吗？而且我觉得性感也体现在我和你以及所有收听节目的其他人照顾自己的方式上。你的自我护理日常是什么样的？是肯定语吗？是写日记吗？是散步吗？是一场疯狂的拳击训练吗？是骑自行车吗？这只是那些。
not on my phone and feel hot and confident that like I am that girl. Like I am that girl that's walking in no matter what I'm wearing, no matter what I'm looking like that day and no matter how, what stage of my cycle I'm in, it's just a confidence and an attitude that I think we as women, to your point earlier, like feel so much imposter syndrome. we feel like do we deserve to be there? And I think like being hot is also just in the way that for me and for you and how everybody else that's listening to this takes care of themselves. Like what does your self-care routine look like? Is that affirmations? Is that journaling? Is that walking? Is that a crazy boxing workout? Is that bicycling, cycling? It's just what
让你感到充实、让你在工作之外感到快乐的事。而且我觉得“性感”这个词，我一想到要把它拆解得太细就有些犹豫，因为它的来源实际上是我在TikTok上一直看到的一种观念：性感女孩这样做，性感女孩那样做。这就像是一种“性感女孩散步”。而我却在想，但我不仅想变得性感。我还想变得聪明。我想快乐。我想健康。我想丰盛。那么，最吸引眼球、最像点击诱饵的三个词是什么？性感、聪明、富有？我当然希望人们快乐健康。但我希望它体现的不仅仅是执着于某一件事，因为我们远不止于此，这正是“性感聪明富有”的全部宗旨。我们远比如何被定义或我们如何定义自己单一方面的总和要丰富得多。
makes you feel fulfilled and makes you feel happy outside of what you do for your job. And I think the words, I get hesitant to like break each down so much because actually where it came from was this idea that I kept seeing on TikTok, hot girls do this, hot girls do that. And it was this like hot girl walk. And I'm like, but I want to be more than just being hot. Like I want to be smart. I want to be happy. I want to be healthy. I want to be abundant. Well, what are the three most catchy words that are clickbait, hot, smart, and rich? Of course I want people to be happy and healthy. But I wanted to embody things that weren't just fixating on one thing because we are so much, and that's the whole purpose of Hot Smart Rich. We are so much more than just one aspect of how we are defined or how we
我们是功能多样、了不起的生物，拥有兴趣、爱好以及我们擅长且想要了解更多的事情。所以性感只是其中一个方面，但它远不止于此。我太喜欢你这种说法了。我也很喜欢你幕后承认这仍然是一种营销，你依然在经营一家商业公司。完全是。我的意思是，我认为这正是最好的企业所具备的——而这常常是——因为我非常乐于合作，而且我分享了这么多的干货，我在互联网上哭泣，在互联网上经历分手，与此同时还加入了一个7500万美元的风投基金并进行投资——这就是真实和脆弱，我觉得这是职场中所缺少的。这就是为什么女性不像看到男性那样看到其他女性走到高位。这就是为什么我们看不到女性获得同样数量的投资资金，因为我们必须回避任何让我们看起来情绪化、或者让我们看起来在工作之外有生活的事情。所以对我来说，我希望女性拥抱她们的各个方面。当然，再次强调，要有我们自己的界限。
define ourselves. We are multifunctional, amazing creatures that have interests and hobbies and things that we are good at that we want to learn more about. So hot is one aspect of it, but it's also so much more than that. I absolutely love how you put that. I also love the behind the scenes acknowledgement that it is still a marketing, you are still running a business. Totally. I mean, I think that's what the best businesses, and this is something that often, because I am so collaborative and I'm giving so many tidbits away, and I'm like crying on the internet and going through breakups on the internet and all the while joining a $75 million
你不能每天哭着去上班。当然不行。但我只是想创造一个空间。最好的企业都是建立在“商业与使命结合”的基础上的。如果你没有一个“为什么”——无论你想成为内容创作者、想创业、想成为投资者——你的“why”（初衷）就是支撑你走下去的动力。如果你没有这个，当事情变得艰难时，你就会放弃。有些日子我只想停下我正在做的事。
venture fund and investing, like, that is the realness and vulnerability that I think is missing from the workforce. That is why women don't see other women at the top like we do men. That is why we don't see women getting the same amount of dollars invested into them because we have to shy away from anything that makes us look emotional or that makes us look like we have a life outside of our jobs. And so for me, it's like I want women to embrace all aspects of them. Obviously, again, with our own boundaries.
然后我想：但是今天那个给我发私信说我帮她筹集到头30万美元的女孩怎么办？如果她没有我的内容，我怎么能停下来？所以我觉得，是的，这当然是营销，但最好的企业确实有着真正的使命和真正的初衷。所以我认为两者兼而有之。我不认为没有其中一个能行得通。我刚才跑题去聊的是：人们经常忘记，归根结底，我是一个投资者。我是一个女商人。
Like you can't go into your job every day crying. Of course not. But I just want to create a space. And the best businesses are built off of business meets mission. Like if you do not have a why, whether you want to be a content creator, you want to start a business, you want to be an investor, your why is what will carry you through. If you don't have that, when things get hard, you will quit. There are days where I just want to stop what I'm doing.
我在职业生涯中做过（你知道的）了不起的事情，因为这是一桩生意，它同样也包含教练指导。但世界运转所依据的货币——就像我一样——仍然是其中的重要部分。当我们融入社会时，我们就会接受这一点。所以它不是一个非营利组织。它是一个使命驱动型的企业，旨在以一种依然让我们处于世界运转经济中心的方式做好事并回馈社会。这说得通吗？完全说得通。完全说得通，就好像——完全说得通，因为你不能免费做所有的事情。这也是我经常遇到的情况，你其实想这样做。那才是理想世界，一个协作的、纯粹协作的、纯粹是以物易物的系统，就像是：我需要你提供这些信息，然后你可以给我。
And then I'm like, but what about the girl today that message me saying that I helped her raise her first $300,000? Like, how could I stop if she doesn't have my content? And so I think, yes, of course, it's marketing, but the best businesses actually have a true mission and a true why. And so I think it's both. Like, I don't think you can have one without the other. And the little tangent I was going on was like, people often forget that at the end of the day, I am an investor. I am a businesswoman.
然后我就想，但今天有个女孩给我发信息说我帮她筹集了前30万美元，这又怎么说呢？如果她没有我的内容，我怎么能停下来呢？所以我觉得，是的，当然，这是营销，但最好的企业其实都有真正的使命和真正的初心。所以我觉得两者兼备。我是说，我觉得缺一不可。我刚才扯远了是想说，人们经常忘记，归根结底，我是一个投资者。我是一个女商人。
I have, you know, done amazing things in my career because it is a business and it is as much coaching. But the currency that the world runs on, like I'm. still a big part of that. We buy into that when we join society. So it's it's not a non-for-profit. It is a mission-driven business to do good and give back in a way that still is keeping us into the economic center of how the world works. Does that make sense? It absolutely does. It totally does where it's like it totally does in the sense that you cannot do everything for free. It's something that I come across a lot, you would like to. That's the ideal world, a collaborative, purely collaborative, purely like barter system where it's like, I need this information from you and you can give me
我在职业生涯中做过许多了不起的事情，你知道的，因为这不仅是一门生意，也是一种指导。但这个世界运转所依赖的货币，我依然是其中的重要部分。我们加入这个社会时就接受了这一点。所以它不是一个非营利组织。这是一个使命驱动的企业，旨在行善并回馈社会，同时让我们依然置身于世界运作的经济核心之中。这说得通吗？完全说得通。真的完全说得通，意思就是你不可能免费做所有事情。这也是我经常遇到的情况，虽然你很想这么做。那将是理想的世界，一种合作的、纯粹合作的、纯粹以物易物的系统，就像是，我需要你提供这些信息，而你可以给我...
this information I need from you, like all these kinds of things. But it is important to be realistic. And I want to focus in on what you said about your why, because if we're returning to this like overbranching original theme of hot, I think that you can, you need to have a why and you need to have a mission when it comes to business, the people who I see are the most attractive, most confident people have a why when it comes to themselves and their purpose. And they walk into spaces and they're almost like, I know why I'm here. I know why I deserve to be here. I have purpose. I have a mission. I have something that I care about that is untouchable, regardless of like what else happens in my personal life, in this room, outside of this room,
我需要你提供的这些信息，就像所有这些事情一样。但保持现实是很重要的。我想把重点放在你关于“为什么”（初衷）的言论上，因为如果我们回到像“魅力”（hot）这样一个宏大、最初的主题，我认为你必须有一个“为什么”，当你经营企业时，你需要有一个使命。我看到那些最有吸引力、最自信的人，当涉及到他们自己和他们的目标时，他们都有一个“为什么”。他们走进一个空间，几乎就像是在说：“我知道我为什么在这里。我知道我为什么配得上这里。我有目标。我有使命。我有我关心的、不可触碰的事情，无论我的个人生活、这个房间里、或者这个房间外面还发生了什么，
whatever anybody says to me. At my core, I have something I care about which no one else can emulate and which no one else can touch. And I think just to give the listeners a piece of advice and a habit, if you want to feel more attractive in yourself and feel more attractive in front of others, finding time to really sit in that space of what do I actually care about, what actually means something to me is honestly a form of emotional armor. It is a form of emotional armor to walk into a new relationship, a new friendship, a room of investors, whoever it is,
无论任何人对我说什么。在我的核心深处，我有一些我关心的事情，这是别人无法模仿的，也是别人无法触及的。我想给听众的一条建议和一个习惯是：如果你想让自己在自我感觉中更有吸引力，在别人面前也更有吸引力，找到时间真正静下心来思考“我到底在乎什么”、“什么对我来说真正有意义”，老实说，这是一种情感盔甲。当你走进一段新感情、一段新友谊、一个投资人的房间，无论是谁，
and be like, okay, I win or lose. This is like, this is all part of this story for me. Have you kind of found that as well with yourself? Totally. I think I can think of like so many different stories I could say, but I'll focus maybe on too when I, and this is a horrible habit that I used to have, I used to vape smoke and I found it very, very, very hard to quit. And it was because it was just like, it was not intentional. I didn't sit with anything. I didn't have any armor, as you said. And going kind of tying everything back into, you know, what we first talked about with slow living is I watched this TED talk from this doctor and it was like, instead of just trying to quit cold turkey, which is just going to make.
然后心里想着：好吧，无论输赢，这都是我故事的一部分。你对自己也有过这种发现吗？完全有。我觉得我可以列举出好多不同的故事，但我可能专注于两个。当我……这是一个我以前有的糟糕习惯，我以前吸电子烟，我发现戒掉它非常非常非常难。那是因为它只是……它不是出于有意的。我没有静下来思考过任何事情。如你所说，我没有任何盔甲。把一切都联系起来，你知道的，我们最初谈到的“慢生活”，我看了一位医生的TED演讲，内容是：不要试图一下子彻底戒掉，因为那只会让你
you feel bad about yourself because you're going to be like, I have to have it. And then you've, you've relapsed you done these things. Actually, I want you to take what your advice is and I want you to engage in the activity. And when you're doing it, I want you to think about how you feel. How do you feel when you do it? And I would feel horrible. I felt nauseous. My finger smelled. I would get a headache. I would then feel like I was out of breath. And so once I actually slowed down, instead of just using my own mental toughness, like, how can I quit so easily? What's my, like, and then be hard on myself, I was able to be like, okay, this doesn't feel good. I don't look good. I'm not happy. Like, it's not making my life better. And it was so much easier for me to quit something when I was able to ladder it up to like being intentional, slowing down. How did I feel? And I think about the those, that's obviously a small example, but on a big scale, I called off my engagement. And I think with, without a mission, without HSR, without a purpose, it would have been life-altering hard because I didn't have a place to live. I had to put all my stuff in storage. I was already 30 when people say that
对自己感觉糟糕，因为你会觉得自己“我必须抽”，然后你又复吸了，做了这些事情。实际上，我希望你采用你的建议，去参与这个活动。当你在做这件事的时候，我想让你想想你的感受。当你做这件事的时候，你感觉如何？我的感觉糟透了。我觉得恶心。我的手指有异味。我会头痛。然后我觉得自己喘不上气来。所以，一旦我真正慢下来，而不是仅仅依靠我自己的心理韧性，比如“我怎么能这么容易戒掉？”、“我的……是什么？”然后对自己严厉，我就能做到：好吧，这感觉不好。我看起来不好。我不高兴。这并没有让我的生活变得更好。当我能够把它和“有意识”、“慢下来”联系起来时，戒掉某种东西对我来说就容易多了。我的感觉如何？我想到了那些……这显然是一个小例子，但在宏大的层面上，我取消了订婚。我想，如果没有使命，没有HSR（Hot Smart Rich），没有目标，那将是改变生活般的艰难，因为我没有地方住。我不得不把我所有的东西都存放在仓库里。当人们说
you're 30s, you have everything figured out and your 20s are for being lost and confused. And I was like, wait, I just gave up a big house in the hills. I don't have anywhere to live. All my friends are in relationships. I'm not getting invited to parties anymore that are couple things and I don't know what I'm doing. But all I knew in that moment was I had a purpose and a why of helping other women. And initially, it started as business. And then when I was going through what I went through, as soon as I talked about it online and opened up about the struggles that I was going through, I not only felt like I was helping disseminate information, I was getting a lot back. I was getting stories of women who had gone through something similar. And that was the moment where I
你三十多岁时，你已经把一切都弄明白了，而你的二十多岁是为了迷茫和困惑时，我已经30岁了。我当时想：等等，我刚刚放弃了山里的大房子。我没有地方住。我所有的朋友都在恋爱中，我不再被邀请参加那些情侣派对，我不知道自己在做什么。但在那一刻，我所知道的全部就是，我有一个帮助其他女性的目标和“初衷”。最初，它是作为一项业务开始的。然后，当我经历我所经历的事情时，一旦我在网上谈论它，并敞开心扉讲述我所经历的挣扎，我不仅觉得我在帮助传播信息，我也得到了很多回报。我收到了许多经历过类似事情的女性的故事。那就是我……的时刻
realize, like, yes, HSR is, you know, business and finance, but it's so much more than that. Because, like I said, we're such multi-hyphenic creatures and we're going to go through so much in our lives that it's hard to just focus on one aspect. And that's kind of the moment that I realized, too, it's like it's not just business 101. It's like life upgrade, glow up, hot, smart, rich life 101. Doing what is best for you, even when it's hot, that's pretty hot. So hard. I can imagine that must have been, that just, must have been excruciating, having to sit in that decision and knowing that either one was going to be difficult. There was not a single easy option out of that. And sometimes in both of those
意识到，是的，HSR是（你知道的）商业和财务，但它远不止于此。因为就像我说的，我们是如此多面复杂的生物，我们在生活中会经历很多事情，以至于很难只关注一个方面。这也是我意识到另一个时刻的时候，它不仅仅是商业101。它是生活升级、蜕变，火辣、聪明、富有生活101。做对你最好的事，即使这很火辣（hot），那也相当火辣。太难了。我可以想象那一定……那一定极其痛苦，不得不坐在那里做出那个决定，并且知道无论哪种选择都很艰难。从那里面没有一个简单的选项。有时在这两个
examples, I do think that one of the best things that you can do for yourself in your life at any point is to do the thing that is incredibly scary and that you have absolutely no certainty is going to work out. Because I honestly believe that it's in those risks where the most potential is held. And the reason that a lot of people don't find their potential is because the fear kind of holds them back as it naturally as it would. And when you kind of walk past that, it's such a visual thing for me, but I think of it as like this big dome, this big like iridescent dome or like iridescent like, kind of like shield or like curtain. And when you step through it, it's suddenly like a whole new world.
例子中，我确实认为你在生活中的任何时刻能为自己做的最好的事情之一，就是去做那件极其可怕的事情，并且你绝对没有任何确信它会成功的事情。因为我真的相信，正是在这些风险中，才蕴藏着最大的潜力。很多人没有发现他们的潜力，原因是因为恐惧在某种程度上阻碍了他们，就像它自然会做的那样。而当你走过那个坎时，对我来说这是一个非常具象的画面，但我想象它就像这个巨大的穹顶，这个巨大的、像彩虹般闪光的穹顶，或者像彩虹般的、某种类似盾牌或窗帘的东西。当你穿过它时，突然就像是一个全新的世界。
Suddenly like, oh, I just did that really, really scary, really hard thing. What's next? If that was like calling off an engagement, that there are so many. people who I can imagine had the desire to do that and didn't do it and now are in relationships that are not right for them, 10, 20, 30 years down the line. And it's so much more scary to sit in a life that you didn't actively choose and know that you have to make peace with it rather than take the risk earlier on, if that makes sense. Exactly. It's like every big moment in my life that has unlocked opportunity has come right after those terrifying.
突然之间，哦，我刚刚做了那个非常非常可怕、非常艰难的事情。接下来是什么？如果这就像是取消订婚一样，有那么多人……我能想象到他们有这样做的愿望却没有做，现在正处于不适合他们的关系中，在10年、20年、30年之后。生活在一个你没有积极选择的生活中，并且知道你必须与之讲和，这要比早点承担风险可怕得多，如果这说得通的话。完全正确。就像我生活中每一个解锁了机会的重大时刻，都紧随那些可怕的、
scary moments. And for me, like, you've envisioned a dome. I envision a wall that you, like, walk through, kick down, whatever it is that you have to get through to get to the other side. And even moving from Canada to the States, like, I knew nobody. I had to sell my house in Canada and I had to deal with visa issues. And like, it was horrible. Like my visas when I first moved here, they were a year long. So think about signing a car lease. Think about signing an apartment. You're like, am I going to be here in a year? I don't know. And so, So everything that has unlocked the next step of my life and the next, the place that I'm at today is exactly where I dreamt of five years ago. And guess what? The goal post keeps moving.
吓人的时刻之后。对我来说，你设想了一个穹顶。我设想了一堵墙，你走过去、踢倒它，无论你需要穿过什么才能到达另一边。甚至从加拿大搬到美国也是如此，我谁也不认识。我不得不卖掉我在加拿大的房子，我不得不处理签证问题。而且这太糟糕了。我刚搬到这里时，我的签证只有一年有效期。所以想想签车贷合同吧。想想租公寓。你会想：一年后我还会在这里吗？我不知道。所以，所有解锁我人生下一步以及我今天所处位置的事情，都正是我五年前梦想的地方。你猜怎么着？目标一直在移动。
But to get to this place that I once dreamt up, it was literally walking down and kicking down and busting down walls. Like relationships where I live, my job, my career, nothing that you want is ever when it's comfortable. Like if things are comfortable, you are not growing. You are not learning. And to your point earlier, I love when people say it's part of your story. We live in a world of storytelling now. We have so much information. It's about curation. It's about it's it's about being able to capture somebody's attention, whether you are a podcaster, a creator, a brand as a storyteller. So if all you've had your whole life is an easy story, who are you going to inspire? Who is going to rally around you? So there is a level of needing to go
但要到达这个我曾经梦想的地方，字面意思就是走过去、踢倒墙壁、砸碎墙壁。比如我住在哪里的人际关系、我的工作、我的职业，你想要的任何东西，在它舒适的时候都不会到来。如果事情很舒适，你就没有在成长。你没有在学习。正如你刚才所说，我喜欢人们说这是你故事的一部分。我们现在生活在一个讲故事的世界里。我们有太多的信息。关键在于精选。关键在于……关键在于能够抓住某个人的注意力，无论你是播客、创作者、品牌，还是一个讲故事的人。所以，如果你的一生只有一个轻松的故事，你要去激励谁？谁会团结在你周围？因此，需要经历某种程度的
through hardship, needing to go through loss, experience grief, experience these things that we so often shy away from, and we want to bury down inside of us. But those are the unlocks to find real connection in this life, real community, real stories. So I think anybody that's going through something that right now that feels like it's unfair or it's, you know, it's so hard, that is going to make you successful one day. And that is what's going to be something that will, inspire somebody else. So it's just about having to go through things instead of just trying to get through something, like go through it and feel it because that is what will fuel you and your next phase of being able to inspire somebody. Also, that is what is going to create better relationships
艰难困苦，需要经历失落，体验悲伤，体验这些我们经常回避、想要埋藏在我们内心的东西。但这些是解锁生活中真正联系、真正社区、真正故事的钥匙。所以我想，任何现在正在经历感觉不公平或如此艰难的事情的人，那将使你有一天获得成功。那将成为能够激励其他人的东西。所以这只是关于去经历事情，而不是试图熬过某件事——去经历它并感受它，因为那将为你和你的下一阶段能够激励他人提供动力。此外，这将为你创造更好的关系
for you, better everything, better habits, better relationships. I don't know, everybody has to have an origin story. I truly believe it. Everyone has like two to three. moments that they're like, that was really difficult. And I came out of it. And for the listeners right now, I want you to think about what those moments are. Two to three moments of hardship where things were really, really difficult that were actually also a point of, like a pivot point in your life that took you on a new path. So we're going to take a short break. But when we return, I want to talk about how to be smart and how to be rich. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
，更好的一切，更好的习惯，更好的关系。我不知道，每个人都必须有一个起源故事。我真的相信这一点。每个人都有两到三个他们觉得“真的很艰难，而我挺过来了”的时刻。对于现在的听众，我希望你们想想那些时刻是什么。两到三个充满艰辛、事情真的非常非常困难、但实际上也是你生活中的转折点并带你走上新道路的时刻。所以我们要休息一下。但当我们回来时，我想谈谈如何变得聪明以及如何变得富有。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
收听《2%》。这就是 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-Persent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击（拍打）小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这段日子的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客，大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时准备聊聊霹雳可卡因，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论霹雳可卡因的第二集。所以我开始发现这其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast,
谢谢你完成这句话。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客，
Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同信任级别。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我的节目，我是基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio 应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭示了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的庭审之战，旨在证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lesbian and Michael Marantini.
你在很大程度上篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯比安（Greg Lesbian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在正义
is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back, Maggie. My favorite part of the hot, smart rich equation is the smart element. I think because when I was a kid, that was kind of all I had. Like, I was not a cute, hot teenager. I was not a wealthy teenager.
在亚利桑那州伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。欢迎回来，麦琪（Maggie）。火辣、聪明、富有公式中最让我喜欢的部分是聪明这个元素。我想是因为自我小时候起，那几乎是我拥有的全部。就像，我不是一个可爱、火辣的青少年。我不是一个富有的青少年。
but when I was like in my hometown like home city the one thing I had was brains and I knew how to work really hard and I think that that has been something that has activated a lot of my a lot of what my life is now was having that element of me and one of the big things that I love about the podcast is that it does make people more educated it really makes them more knowledgeable about themselves there's like that huge element of psycho education. I think that is just so, so important. How do you go about expanding your kind of intellect and your EQ and your IQ? Because you are a highly knowledgeable individual.
但当我在我的家乡……家乡城市时，我唯一拥有的东西就是头脑，我知道如何非常努力地工作。我认为那是激活了我的很多……我的现在的生活很大一部分的一个要素，就是拥有我这一特质。我非常喜欢这个播客的一大原因在于，它确实让人变得更有教育意义，它真的让他们对自我有更多的了解，这里面有巨大的心理教育元素。我认为这真的非常非常重要。你是如何着手拓展你的那种智力、情商和智商的？因为你是一个知识渊博的人。
You have your hands in a lot of different parts in terms of like the content you consume, the papers you read, like where you get inspiration. So give the listeners your formula, if you will. I love this question. So I think it comes down to your diet, which seems counterintuitive for the smart pillar. But what I mean by that is your information diet is so important. And what you consume and who you surround yourself with is truly what they say is like you are the byproduct of the five closest people to you or the people you surround yourself with the most. And I think I've gone through this a lot when you're in your 20s. You really are focused on being invited to the right thing. and being around this vast amount of people and being seen at the right spots. And when you do go through this like end of 20s, early 30s, you kind of, you realize that it's really around the quality of people that you're around, the quality of events, the quality of conversations that you're having. And so I think as it relates to kind of how I absorb information, I like to
你在很多不同的方面都有涉猎，比如你消费的内容、你阅读的论文、你灵感来源的地方。所以，如果你愿意的话，把你的公式分享给听众吧。我喜欢这个问题。所以我觉得这归结于你的饮食，这对于聪明这个支柱来说似乎有点违反直觉。但我的意思是，你的信息饮食非常重要。你消费什么以及你周围都是什么人，真正印证了那句话，即你是离你最近的五个人或你周围最多的人的副产品。我想我在20s时经历了很多这样的事情。你真的专注于被邀请去对的地方，
surround myself with people that talk about ideas. They don't talk about other people. And if I am around people that I feel are constantly talking about people. Like, listen, we're all human. It is human nature. It is one of the sins that was put on this world earth that, yes, some people are going to gossip. So I'm not saying as soon as you hear somebody, but for any listeners that feel like their conversations with the people in their lives are always about other people, that's a really bad sign that you are not on a path of increasing your intellect. So as hard and scary as it is, it's about kind of shrinking your circle down and finding the moment that and the conversations and the people that make your world bigger and brighter and not darker and
和大量的人在一起，并在正确的地点被看到。当你经历20s末、30s初时，你会……你会意识到这实际上关乎你身边的人的质量、活动的质量、你正在进行的对话的质量。所以我觉得，关于我如何吸收信息，我喜欢……
shallower. So I think that's the first thing. And then again, your information diet. So like, what are you spending time on? Do you subscribe to newsletters that challenge a point of thinking? Do you, are you able to read and have conversations with people that think differently than you? In terms of like what I'm consuming on a daily basis, I used to wake up every single day, check social media and actually scroll social media for hours or too long. Now, okay, maybe I check it for five minutes. And then I immediately go to my email and I'm going through the newsletters of what I have subscribed to and that I want to actually like think about for the day. So that can range from things that are pop culture like future party is one that I love to something like axios, which is
周围都是谈论思想的人。他们不谈论别人。如果我和那些我觉得不断在谈论别人的人在一起……听着，我们都是人。这是人性。这是被放在这个地球上的罪孽之一，是的，有些人会八卦。所以我不是说一旦你听到有人这样，但对于任何觉得他们与生活中人们的对话总是围绕着其他人的听众来说，这是一个非常糟糕的信号，表明你并没有走在提升智力的道路上。所以，尽管这很难、很可怕，但关键在于缩小你的圈子，找到那些让你的世界变得更大、更明亮而不是更黑暗、
where I get venture capital and finance news. I subscribe and pay for everything from B.OF, business of fashion, WWD to get the beauty and fashion side to like New York Times and Wall Street Journal. I love reading different people's POVs and instead of just believing it to be true is really like sitting with and again slowing down and being mindful about what's their opinion, how do I think about it? What would I think differently about? And do I have any resources to back up why my opinion might be different? So that's kind of my way that I expand. I listen to so many podcasts. You are literally my favorite podcast, even though I'm not in my 20s. I live for it. And then I read books and I go out in the world. And I instead of when I'm at Sephora and I am like, oh God, am I going to spend $30 in this eyebrow pencil, I'm studying people. I'm watching what brands are people going towards? How are they doing their marketing at Summer Fridays now? That to me is all increasing my intellect and taking inventory.
更浅薄的时刻、对话和人。所以我觉得这是第一件事。然后再次强调，是你的信息饮食。比如，你把时间花在什么上？你是否订阅了那些挑战思考观点的简报？你是否能够阅读并与那些与你想法不同的人进行对话？就我日常消费的内容而言，我以前每天醒来第一件事就是查看社交媒体，实际上是在社交媒体上滚动浏览好几个小时或者太长时间。现在，好吧，也许我查阅五分钟。然后我立即去看我的电子邮件，浏览我订阅的简报，以及我今天真正想去思考的内容。所以这可以涵盖从流行文化类的内容——比如“Future Party”是我喜欢的一个——到像“Axios”这样
because I'm being mindful about what I can learn other than just being passively going through life. That is the way that you don't grow your intellect. You just let the world lead you instead of being your own CEO of your life. Something that I was thinking the other day was when was the last time that you learned something new and truly learned something new the way that you would learn something new at school. You think about all those early years. We are just a sponge for new information. We are a sponge for opinions, for history, for...
我获取风险投资和金融新闻的地方。我订阅并支付了从B.OF（Business of Fashion）、WWD（获取美容和时尚方面的信息）到《纽约时报》和《华尔街日报》的所有内容。我喜欢阅读不同的人的观点，而不是盲目相信它是真的，而是真正地坐下来——再次强调，慢下来并对什么是他们的观点、我是如何看待它的、我对它会有什么不同的思考、以及我是否有任何资源来支持为什么我的观点可能不同——保持正念。所以这差不多是我拓展知识的方式。我听了超级多的播客。你简直是我最喜欢的播客，尽管我已经不在20多岁了。我为它而活。然后我读书，我走向外面的世界。当我走进丝芙兰（Sephora），然后我想，天哪，我要在这支眉笔上花30美元吗？不，我在研究人们。我在观察人们在倾向于什么品牌？他们现在在Summer Fridays（美妆品牌）是怎么做营销的？对我来说，这全都是在提升我的智力和盘点，
grammar, literature, and then it all becomes centered mainly on what we do for work. And I've typically found that there is this weird low between like our late 20s, early 30s, even like early 20s where we feel very boring and we feel a lot less interested in our lives. And you have these conversations with people sometimes where you're like, what are we even talking about? Like we can't talk about this for the third, fifth, you know, seventh time because of, I think, an educational and information, an informational deficit. I'm going to pull something that you said from before about when you used to be addicted to smoking and vaping.
因为我保持正念，思考除了被动度过生活之外我还能学到什么。这就是那种你不会增长智力的方式。你只是让世界牵着你的鼻子走，而不是成为你自己人生的CEO。我前几天在想的一件事是，你上次学到新东西是什么时候，真正像你在学校里学新东西那样学到新东西？你想想那些早期的年岁。我们就像海绵一样吸收新信息。我们是吸收观点、历史、
Notice how that makes you feel. And the same thing here. Notice how not providing yourself with stimulation and information and a real, like, juicy you form of entertainment that is, you know, the news and that is articles and that is other people's knowledge. How does that make you feel? Do you feel a bit more shallow? Do you feel like you could do with something more interesting in your life? I love your formula for like what newsletters you subscribe to. Substack also amazing. I really enjoyed like starting my day listening to like the daily or we have like the daily Oz, the daily Australian, which is like it's so Australian there. So listen
语法、文学的海绵，然后这一切都主要集中在我们为工作所做的事情上。我通常发现，在我们20s晚期、30s初期，甚至20s初期之间，存在着一种奇怪的低谷，那时我们觉得自己很无聊，对生活的兴趣大大降低。有时你与人们进行这样的对话，你会想：我们在聊些什么啊？我们不能因为教育和信息的赤字，把这个话题聊第三次、第五次、第七次吧。我要借用你之前说过的话，关于你以前对吸烟和电子烟上瘾的那段经历。
to it if you're Australian because if you're not, it's like crocodile attack. What does that mean for like, what does that mean for politics? Because, yeah, those two things are linked. And even doing small things, and I know everyone's obsessed with like the New York Times like wordling connections. I love doing that. One more thing. This is something that I should have said right at the beginning when I was giving my
注意那带给你的感受。这里也是一样。注意不给自己提供刺激、信息以及一种真正像样、多汁的娱乐形式（即新闻、文章以及其他人的知识）会带给你什么感受。你觉得自己变得有点浅薄了吗？你觉得你的生活中是不是可以加点更有趣的东西？我超级喜欢你关于你订阅了哪些简报的公式。Substack也很棒。我真的很喜欢以听《The Daily》或像《The Daily Oz》（澳大利亚新闻）这样的节目开始我的一天，那节目太澳大利亚了，所以如果是澳大利亚人就听吧，如果不是，听起来就像是鳄鱼袭击。这对……对政治意味着什么？因为，是的，这两件事是联系在一起的。甚至做一些小事情，我知道每个人都痴迷于《纽约时报》的 Wordle 和 Connections。我很喜欢玩那个。还有一件事。这是我一开始给出我自己的个人公式时就应该说的一件事。
own personal formula. The good weekend quiz. So fun. Me and my partner do it every single Saturday morning. we get our coffee, we sit down, all our friends do it as well, and it is so much fun because then we can compare answers. Even my family does it. They have it on Instagram. It's called the Good Weekend Quiz. And it's such a great way to just be like, okay, I'm not immediately waking up and scrolling my phone for the next eight hours. Like there is some diversity in what I am feeding my brain, my informational
《Good Weekend Quiz》（好周末问答）。太有趣了。我和伴侣每个星期六早晨都会做这个，我们拿着咖啡坐下来，我们所有的朋友也都做，这太有趣了，因为这样我们可以比较答案。甚至我的家人们也做。他们在Instagram上有这个。它叫《Good Weekend Quiz》。这是一个绝佳的方式，可以让自己觉得：好吧，我不是一醒来就在接下来的八个小时里刷手机。我的大脑摄入的内容、也就是你所说的信息饮食，是有多样性的。
diet, as you called it. It is so critical. And I love that you said your partner and you do that because we spend so much time with our partner. And if you look at your relationship and you don't have those healthy habits and rituals and routines, like that is a sign that it will be harder in the future. I think that was one of the things that made me really take a very hard look at my life when I was thinking 20 years down the line, like what is going to bind us and bond us? And it's those little rituals. Like my partner and I now, we do and we send each other in news that are back and with every single Sunday when it comes out of our favorite motivational quotes for the week, what we want to take with us. And it's like these little things that it's not the big things.
这至关重要。我很高兴你说你和你的伴侣会这样做，因为我们花了太多时间与伴侣在一起。如果你审视你们的关系，却发现没有那些健康的习惯、仪式和常规，那就是未来会更艰难的信号。我想这是让我真正非常严厉地审视自己生活的事情之一，当我考虑20年后的光景时，比如是什么在维系和绑定我们？就是这些小小的仪式。就像我和我的伴侣现在这样，我们会做这件事，并且把我们最喜欢的每周励志名言、我们想带走的东西，在每周日一出来时就互相发邮件。就像这些小事情——不是那些宏大的事情。
What I've learned in all my failures is it's not the big moments that really change your life. It's the small things that you do every single day. The rituals you have to make you feel hot, make you smarter, make you have more financial abundance. And if you don't take inventory of the small things, how much time are you spending on social media? Your life. will go so fast and you will not know where you went with it. So I think it's just being really cognizant of those little things like what you guys do every single week together is so important. Also novelty makes time literally feel longer. There was this amazing study about it a couple of years ago. The older we get, the reason why it feels like time is going faster and faster and faster is because
我在我所有的失败中所学到的是，真正改变你生活的不是那些重大的时刻。而是你每天都在做的那些小事。让你感到火辣、让你变得更聪明、让你拥有更多财务富足的仪式。如果你不对这些小事进行盘点，你在社交媒体上花多少时间？你的生活会过得飞快，而你甚至不知道它都去哪了。所以我认为，对那些小事情保持高度的清醒认知——比如你们俩每周一起做的事情——是非常重要的。还有，新鲜感实际上会让时间感觉更长。几年前有一项关于这方面的惊人研究。我们越老，之所以觉得时间过得越来越快、越来越快，是因为
we have fewer novel experiences. So if you want to feel like your year is two years, three years long, give yourself more novelty scrolling on your phone we all do it not novelty uh doing the same you know watching the same thing every single night same routine eating at the same places not novelty new experiences literally give time i actually um heard one thing that's changed my life actually this year on that is if you want to increase your brain elasticity you need to do things out of routine so even if you want to go to the same grocery store walk the path differently than you usually do. If you want to do the same hike every single day, do it the opposite way down because that will actually help create new brain structures and it won't just give you the same thing
我们拥有的新鲜体验越来越少了。所以如果你想让你的感觉像过了两年、三年一样长，那就给自己多一点新鲜感——在手机上刷屏我们都在做，这不是新鲜感；做着同样的事情（比如每晚看同一个节目）、同样的日常、在同一个地方吃饭，都不是新鲜感。新的体验实际上能给时间……我实际上……今年在这方面听到了一件改变我生活的事情，那就是如果你想增加大脑弹性，你需要打破常规做一些事情。所以即使你想去同一家杂货店，也要走一条平时不常走的路。如果你想每天进行同一次远足，那就反方向下山，因为这实际上有助于建立新的大脑结构，而且它不会只给你每天都一样的老套路，
every single day, which will make not only time feel longer, but also will actually increase your neuroplasticity. It's a hundred percent true kind of test. The science is there. The way that I always you're like, yes, I got it right. The way I always explain it is, a big law, imagine like a big field at a public park. And, you know, of course there is like the path around. And that's the path that you're walking every day. But then you start walking off the path and you start creating these little paths through the grass that are actually making like the circuit faster or giving like giving nuance.
这不仅会让时间感觉更长，还会真正增加你的神经可塑性。百分之百真实的测试。科学就摆在那里。我一直以来解释的方式——你会觉得：耶，我答对了。我一直以来解释的方式是，想象一下一个公共公园里的大片草地。你知道，当然有一条环绕的小路。那是你每天都在走的小路。但随后你开始偏离小路，你开始在草地上开辟出这些小径，它们实际上让回路更快了，或者提供了细微的差别。
That's how I always like to think of it is like these little runoff paths. And you're absolutely totally right. Neuoplasticity as we get older. Your brain is still rewind. your brain is still growing. I know there is this saying that, you know, our brain only fully develops, matures at 25. Not correct. Not correct. Our life is a constant pattern of neuroplasticity, synaptic pruning, growing like new connections, long-term potentiation. It's absolutely wild. So you can completely reprogram, restructure how your brain thinks
这就是我一直喜欢思考它的方式，就像这些小小的分流小径。你完全、绝对是对的。随着我们变老，神经可塑性依然存在。你的大脑仍在重组，你的大脑仍在生长。我知道有这样一种说法，即我们的大脑只在25岁时才完全发育成熟。不对。不对。我们的一生都是神经可塑性、突触修剪、生长新连接、长时程增强的持续模式。这绝对是疯狂的。所以你完全可以重新编程、重构你的大脑对某事物的思考方式，
about something at 35, at 40, at 50. Wait, I love that so much. And also just like, again, you're using words that I don't understand yet, but I'm so excited about that. And I'm going to, like, write them down and go and look at that because that's just a way where instead of feeling stupid or feeling like, I don't know that. I'm sure a lot of people listen to be like, I actually don't know the words that you just said. And that's okay because it means I'm going to learn something new. And so I think it's just about like being open for the journey and being honest. Like I will remember diligenting one of the hardest deals I've ever deligensed. I called my sister, who's now my business partner, and I was like, hey, I have no clue what any of this means. It doesn't mean that I don't belong in the room. I just don't know how to do a model like this. Can you please help me? And I think it's just being able to have even that level of awareness where it's like, it doesn't make me not able or deserving to do this, but I actually need your help. You will be surprised how far that will take you in your life. 100%. Finally, let's turn to how to be richer in our 20s in our life and kind of the habits that build that financial foundation. And I'm going to rest
在35岁时，在40岁时，在50岁时。等等，我太喜欢这个了。而且，就像，再次强调，你用的词汇我还不懂，但我对此感到非常兴奋。我要把它写下来，然后去查阅，因为这正是一种方式：与其感到愚蠢或觉得自己“我不知道那个”，我相信很多听众听了会想“我其实不知道你刚才说的那些词”。这没关系，因为这意味着我要学到新东西。所以我想这只是关于对这段旅程保持开放和诚实。就像我记得对我经历过最艰难的一笔交易进行尽职调查（diligenting）时，我打电话给我的姐姐——她现在是我的商业伙伴，我说：“嘿，我完全不知道这代表什么意思。这并不意味着我不配待在这个房间里。我只是不知道怎么做这样一个模型。你能帮帮我吗？”我想，能够拥有甚至那种程度的自我觉察——它并不意味着我没有能力或不配做这件事，但我确实需要你的帮助——你会惊讶于这在你的生活中能带你走多远。百分之百。最后，让我们转向如何在20s、在我们的生活中变得更加富有，以及建立这种财务基础的习惯。我要非常、非常重度地
very, very heavily on your knowledge here because I know the psychology behind money. I don't know the nuances and the details. But right off the bat, I do want to ask, because this is probably one of our biggest influences on how we see money in adulthood. How did you grow up seeing money in your family in Canada? Yeah. I grew up really like privileged in a lot of ways where I never had to worry about putting food on the table. I never had to worry about certain things and I feel so lucky because of that. I grew up with a really interesting dynamic between my mom and dad with money, which has created my own trauma in being, I think, so driven. I watched, you know, my mom, she was a waitress and my dad was a taxi driver and they both put my dad
依赖你这里的知识，因为我懂金钱背后的心理学。我不懂其中的细微差别和细节。但一开始，我确实想问，因为这可能是我们对成年后如何看待金钱的最大影响之一。你在加拿大的家庭中长大时，是如何看待金钱的？是的。我在很多方面都成长得挺优渥的，我从来不用担心温饱问题。我从来不用担心某些事情，为此我感到非常幸运。我在父母之间经历了一种非常有趣的关于金钱的动态，这造就了我自己的创伤，让我变得如此拼搏。我看着，你知道的，我妈妈曾经是一名女服务员，我爸爸是一名出租车司机，他们俩平等地供我爸爸
through law school equally. And, you know, they, without telling too much of their story, I grew up just knowing and witnessing that I wanted to have my own financial security because my mom ended up being an amazing stay-at-home mom. She went back to school and got her master's, and she's now a Pilates instructor, and she's done incredible things. But, you know, we grew up primarily with my dad, who was the primary breadwinner. And I just remember growing up thinking, like I need to have my own financial money. I need to be able to make my own decisions. I need to be able to not marry somebody and have to make all my decisions together with that person. I need to be able to be financially independent. And so I thought about money in a lot of ways where I knew it was
读法学院。而且，你知道的，在不过多透露他们的故事的情况下，我成长过程中只知道并目睹了我想拥有自己的经济安全感，因为我妈妈最终成了一位出色的全职妈妈。她重返学校取得了硕士学位，现在是一名普拉提教练，她做了一些不可思议的事情。但是，你知道的，我们主要和爸爸一起长大，爸爸是主要的经济支柱。我只记得在成长过程中想过，我需要有我自己的财务资金。我需要能够自己做决定。我需要能够不依附于某个人，并且必须与那个人一起做出所有决定。我需要能够经济独立。所以我对金钱有很多看法，我知道它是
abundant. I knew if I thought about money like a currency, it comes and it goes, that I wouldn't feel like so attached when I would lose money. And I think that's, really shaped a lot of the decisions where I was okay putting money at risk when I think a lot of other people maybe weren't because I did grow up with an abundance mindset towards money. So I'll give you an example. I met the woman who was the first actually female fundraiser for Harvard's Endowment Fund. And she was telling me the most interesting thing she noticed when she worked on the Goldman Sachs floor when she was first starting her career is when somebody would leave Goldman and it was a man and they were starting a business, all the guys would easily, without asking, without even knowing the
丰盛的。我知道如果我把金钱看作一种流通货币，它有来有往，当我失去金钱时，我就不会感到那么依恋。我认为这极大地塑造了许多决策，在这些决策中，当我认为许多其他人可能不会时，我愿意将资金置于风险之中，因为我确实对金钱抱有丰盛的心态。所以我举个例子。我遇到了哈佛捐赠基金历史上第一位女性募款人。她告诉我，当她刚开始职业生涯时，在髙盛的交易大厅工作时，她注意到最有趣的事情是：如果有人离开高盛——是个男的——而且他们要创业，所有的男生都会毫不费力地、甚至不问、甚至不了解
business, would be like, here's 10K to get started. And she noticed the women were like, but it's 10K. Like, what if you lose the 10K? Instead of what could I get if I give you the 10K? And they thought of money so finitely. They didn't think about it as an infinite currency. Like there's more of where that came from. The only currency that we don't have more of is time. And so I think it's interesting. now when she went over and she was fundraising for Harvard on how you even get women to talk and open up their pocketbooks about money, I would say I've leaned a little bit more towards men where I think about it of like, what could this do for me? Money is a tool that I can utilize to get where I want to go. But of course, I have to put it at risk or put it to work first
这个业务，就会说：“这里有1万美元拿去起步。”她注意到女性则会说：“但这可是1万美元啊。如果你把这1万美元亏了怎么办？”而不是“如果我把这1万美元给你，我能得到什么？”她们对金钱的看法非常有限。她们没有把它看作一种无限的流通货币。就像“钱还会从原来的地方赚回来”。我们没有更多来源的唯一货币就是时间。所以我觉得很有趣的是，现在当她为哈佛募款时，关于如何让女性开口并掏钱包谈论金钱，我会说我更倾向于男性一点，我是这样想的：“这能为我做些什么？”金钱是我可以利用来实现我想去的地方的工具。但当然，我必须先把资金置于风险之中或让它们运转起来，
because it's not just going to grow inherently just because it's money. It doesn't grow on trees. So I don't know if that fully answers your question, but I think the way I've thought about money is in one way very abundantly and in the other way, very much knowing that I needed to make money myself, that I never needed to rely on somebody else to help me make decisions for me. I think that's an absolutely beautiful philosophy to have. And it definitely answered my question. Okay, good. Most certainly. It definitely did. and I don't blame women for being a lot tighter without cash, right?
因为钱不会仅仅因为它是钱就自然而然地增长。钱不会长在树上。所以，我不知道这是否完全回答了你的问题，但我看待金钱的方式一方面是非常丰盛的，另一方面，非常清楚地知道我需要自己赚钱，我永远不需要依赖别人来帮我做决定。我认为这绝对是一个美丽的哲学。而且它确实回答了我的问题。好吧，很好。当然回答了。它确实回答了。我不怪女性对现金抓得更紧，对吧？
Because for a lot of us, and you know, I have no excuse because my mom was the breadwinner and my dad was a stay-at-home dad. So I have no excuse for having this belief. But I think for a lot of us, we do see those situations where our mothers don't have as much financial, perhaps freedom or literacy. and the only thing we know is to save. That is like the golden rule, right? We're all taught to save money.
因为对我们很多人来说，你知道的，我没有借口，因为我妈妈是经济支柱，我爸爸是全职爸爸。所以我没有借口产生这种信念。但我想对我们很多人来说，我们确实看到那些情况，我们的母亲没有那么多的财务自由或理财知识，而我们唯一知道的就是存钱。这就像是黄金法则，对吧？我们都被教导要存钱。
And it's incredibly smart and wise to do that. But then I think that there is this element of like, you can save money for your entire life, but sometimes risking some of the extra cash that you have means that you are going to be better off. And it is all about how we think about risk, right? men have been taught to be a lot more risk positive, which means that you think even about as when we were children,
这样做是非常聪明和明智的。但随后我认为有这样一个因素，你可以一辈子存钱，但有时冒着拥有的一些额外现金的风险，意味着你会过得更好。这一切都关于我们如何看待风险，对吧？男性被教导要更加具有风险积极性，这意味着你甚至会想到，当我们还是孩子的时候，
and again, not to make it a gendered thing, but it's just like an easy way to split this up. As children, you know, young boys are encouraged to go and do the adventurous stuff, to go and be quite physical, to trust their own intuition. Girls are taught to be a lot more careful, cautious, you know, just to kind of stay back. And you might not think that's important, but it does actually create your approach to risk.
再说一次，不是要把这变成一个性别问题，但这只是划分它的一个简单方式。作为孩子，你知道的，小男孩被鼓励去做好冒险的事情，去变得非常有体力，去相信他们自己的直觉。女孩被教导要更加小心、谨慎，你知道的，就是呆在后面。你可能认为这不重要，但它确实塑造了你对待风险的方式。
So you can be risk positive. You embrace risk. You are not too concerned about the loss. It can be risk neutral where you're kind of like on the fence and then risk inverse, which is even when an investment, a risk, anything has the potential to have an incredible upside, you will still hold back because the uncertainty of what could happen is so much more cognitively and mentally powerful to you and you give that example of people on the floor at Goldman Sachs, right? Those men giving out 10K. And I really did think you were going to be like,
所以你可以对风险持积极态度。你拥抱风险。你不太担心损失。也可以是风险中立，你有点像处于观望状态，然后是风险厌恶，也就是即使一项投资、一项风险、任何事情都有可能带来巨大的回报，你仍然会退缩，因为对可能发生的事情的不确定性在认知和精神上对你来说要强大得多，你举了高盛交易大厅里人们的例子，对吧？那些分发一万美元的男人。我真的以为你会说，
and then the women would leave and they wouldn't give them any money, which I'm sure also happened. Yeah. Really? Yeah, I can imagine. But it's interesting seeing that example of like, women have been taught to be so much more risk adverse that in those situations where they could have done really, really well, perhaps, almost how they were socialized and mentally, like they weren't afforded the same opportunity or they didn't have the same mindset to embrace that risk, which is just so interesting applying that to the literal example you just gave me. It's also challenging because, you know, I'm in my 30s now and you think about babies and families and you think about taking time off, right?
然后女性会离开，他们不会给她们任何钱，我确信这也发生过。是的。真的吗？是的，我可以想象。但看到这个例子很有趣，女性被教导要更加风险厌恶，以至于在那些她们本可以做得非常非常好的情况下，也许，就像她们被社会化和心理塑造的方式一样，她们没有被赋予相同的机会，或者她们没有相同的心态去拥抱这种风险，这套用在你刚刚给我的字面例子上真是太有趣了。这也是具有挑战性的，因为，你知道的，我现在三十多岁了，你会想到婴儿和家庭，你会想到休假，对吧？
And in Canada, we're so lucky to have a year Matt leave. But that does a lot for your career if you're out of the workforce for a year. And so there inherently is a conversation that needs to be had around the way that money and financial independence and being able to really have women work together with men, but also just to be able to make sure that, like, we are going to have different systems. if you are taking time off to have a child because it inherently will just affect your potential if you are taking out a year, two years, three years, three years, family, children that you have from the workforce. And that is something that is, I don't think, talked about enough. And that's the really fun thing about building HSR as a brand, but having me really be
在加拿大，我们非常幸运能有一年的产假。但如果你离开职场一年，这对你的职业生涯影响很大。因此，围绕金钱、财务独立以及真正让女性与男性合作的方式，自然需要进行对话，同时也要确保，如果为了生孩子而休假，我们将会有不同的系统，因为它本质上会影响你的潜力，如果你离开职场一年、两年、三年、家庭、孩子。我认为这并没有得到足够的讨论。这就是将HSR打造成一个品牌的真正有趣之处，也是让我真正能够
able to talk about my own experiences because that is something, you know, in my early 30s, I am starting to think about. And it is scary. And so being able to have that. conversation is something that feels like you're not alone when you go through those big life decisions that will change the course of your life. It gives you freedom and I think freedom is valuable, whoever you are, whatever age, any gender, whoever. You want the freedom to have the life you want. I'm going to give you two final rapid fire questions because we have been talking
谈论我自己的经历的原因，因为那是你知道的，在我三十岁出头的时候，我开始思考的事情。这很可怕。因此，能够进行这种对话让人感觉，当你经历那些将改变你生活轨迹的人生重大决定时，你并不孤单。它给你自由，我认为自由是有价值的，无论你是谁，无论什么年龄，任何性别，无论谁。你想要拥有自己想要的生活的自由。我要问你最后两个快问快答问题，因为我们已经聊了
for almost an hour. Had it really? I just looked at the time and I was like, yeah. And I was like, oh, we're not even halfway through, but I've got two more rapid-fire questions for you. The first one is, what is one money lesson that you think we should all be learning earlier in our early 20s, in our 20s in our 20s in general? I think especially in your 20s, don't be afraid to take risks. Like, if you want to know the secret of the bros club, it is that they bet on themselves. And I was, if I hadn't been forced to leave my job, I don't think I ever,
快一个小时了。真的吗？我刚看了看时间，心想，是的。然后我说，哦，我们甚至还没过半，但我还有两个快问快答问题要问你。第一个是，你认为我们所有人在二十出头、二十多岁的时候，都应该更早学习的一条理财经验是什么？我认为尤其是在二十多岁时，不要害怕冒险。如果你想知道兄弟会的秘密，那就是他们敢于押注自己。如果我没有被迫离开我的工作，我想我永远不会，
would have. Like, I honestly don't think I would have bet on myself. But I really think, and there's different seasons of life. And like I said, as you get into your 30s and your 40s, you're in the phase of life of, like, taking care of other people, dependence. Your 20s are for failing and having nothing and figuring it out and being like, what am I going to do next? So especially in your 20s, I'm not going to tell you, like, don't buy that latte. Like, don't do this. No, like, just take more risks, like, and whether that's starting a side hustle, starting a business, like, I have failed so many times in every aspect of my life. And I wish I had started earlier. I wish I had started failing earlier. I was so afraid to fail. And I wish I had just done, I wish I had taken more risks in
会离开。老实说，我不认为我会押注自己。但我真的认为，人生有不同的季节。就像我说的，当你进入三十多岁和四十多岁时，你处于照顾其他人、依赖者的生活阶段。你的二十多岁是用来失败、一无所有、摸索并思考我接下来要做什么的。所以特别是在二十多岁时，我不会告诉你，不要买那杯拿铁。不要这样做。不，去冒更多风险，无论是开启副业还是创业，我在生活的方方面面都失败过很多次。我希望我能早点开始。我希望我能早点开始经历失败。我曾如此害怕失败。我希望我曾在
every aspect of my life. But also the more important lesson is this idea that like life is about getting rejected. It's about failing. And the more that you like get comfortable with that in really small, like not high-risk situations, the more it will pay off when you actually have something that you need to go and ask for. And that, especially when you're young and you're afraid of ruffling feathers or your woman, is just uncomfortable to do. So if you can just start doing that tomorrow, I don't do it every single day, but I do it pretty often. And it honestly helps build my confidence. My final question, if you had to add one more word to hot, smart, rich, what would it be? happy.
生活的方方面面冒更多风险。但更重要的教训是，生活就是关于被拒绝的。它关乎失败。你越能在非常小、风险不高的情况下对此感到习惯，当你真正有需要去争取的东西时，它就越能带来回报。尤其是当你年轻、害怕惹事生非或者你是女性时，这做起来就是不舒服。所以如果你明天就能开始这样做，我不是每天都这样做，但我经常这样做。老实说，这有助于建立我的自信。我的最后一个问题，如果你必须为热辣、聪明、富有（hot, smart, rich）再加一个词，会是什么？快乐。
Oh, I love that. Hot, smart, rich, happy. I was thinking even like, is she going to say kind? Is she going to say abundant? Is she going to say lucky? I was thinking about it earlier. I was like, I wonder what she's going to say.
哦，我太喜欢了。热辣、聪明、富有、快乐。我甚至在想，她会说善良吗？她会说丰盛吗？她会说幸运吗？我之前一直在想。我在想，不知道她会说什么。
I think happy. I think, like, we are so blessed to be on this earth. I just can't even believe it sometimes. And I'm like, if you're not happy and you're not having fun, then you need to reconsider stuff because it should be fun, not always, but if you're not having fun, you're not happy, like, there's no point in having everything in the world. So definitely, I would say it would be like, happy, hots for rich. I like it. I love how she's already like, where does that fit? Yeah. The true business mind. Well,
我觉得是快乐。我觉得，我们能来到这个地球上是如此有福气。有时我甚至不敢相信。我在想，如果你不快乐，你没有在享受乐趣，那你需要重新审视一些事情，因为它应该是有趣的，虽然不总是这样，但如果你没有乐趣，你不快乐，拥有世界上的一切就毫无意义了。所以绝对的，我会说是快乐，hot smart rich happy。我喜欢。我喜欢她已经在想，这词放哪合适呢？是的。真正的商业头脑。那么，
I want to thank you so much for coming on the podcast and for giving us, like, a little bit of, like, different advice. Like, I don't always talk, I rarely talk business on the show, but it's so valuable to think about the mindset hacks and the psychology and yeah the whole perspective that we can have towards being successful in this decade and beyond so where can they find you if they want more of your content maggie sellers on instagram and on ticot just put an underscore at the end and then if you just search up hot smart rich on google hopefully it comes up because we're trying to take over the internet yeah and honestly cannot recommend it more you also have a newsletter, is that correct? Yes, it jobs every single Sunday. It's honestly like a very
我要非常感谢你来到这个播客，并给我们提供了一些不同的建议。我不经常谈论，我很少在这个节目中谈论商业，但思考心态秘诀、心理学以及我们对在这个十年及以后取得成功所能持有的整体视角，是如此宝贵。如果他们想要你的更多内容，在哪里可以找到你？Maggie Sellers，在Instagram和TikTok上，在最后加上一个下划线就行了。如果你在谷歌上搜索hot smart rich，希望它能弹出来，因为我们正试图接管互联网。是的，老实说，极力推荐。你还有一个时事通讯，对吗？是的，每个星期天都有。老实说，它拥有
like cult-like readership, which has been so cool and fun. And I do a little bit of mix of personal stuff, consumer news, we do business breakdowns, and then we have our podcast launching very shortly. Yes, I was going to say, keep your eye out for that. We will definitely let the listeners know when it's time to tune in. But again, thank you so much to Maggie. And until next time, you guys, if you did enjoy this, this episode makes sure to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, the IHart Radio app, wherever you are listening, and follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to see behind the scenes content, if you want to know who our next December guest is,
非常像邪教一般的读者群，这真的很酷很有趣。我做一点个人内容的混合，消费者新闻，我们做商业剖析，然后我们的播客很快就会上线。是的，我正要说，密切关注那个节目。当可以收听时，我们一定会让听众知道。再次非常感谢Maggie。下次见，伙计们，如果你确实喜欢这个，这集节目请务必在Apple Podcasts、Spotify、iHeartRadio App上留下五星好评，无论你在哪里收听，并在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看到幕后内容，如果你想知道我们十二月的下一位嘉宾是谁，
and if you want to see more of what we're doing. Until next time, stay safe, be kind. Please be gentle to yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take. the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side
如果你想看到更多我们的动态。下次见，注意安全，保持善良。请对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中坚韧精神、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode, we pick a year
成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。在《Look Back at it》播客中，对于1979年，那对我是个大时刻，84对我来说也很重大。我是Sam Jay，我是Alex English。每期节目，我们挑选一个年份，
unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year For black people
剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么和朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起挺过来的。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了
Listen to Look Back at it On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲，
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控是双胞胎的生父。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，太多了。我对测试动了一次手脚。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。Greg Gillespie和Michael Ranchini。我惊呆了。我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。Laura，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。